attention shoppers are you thinking of
having a baby but want to test the
waters with something that's not the
same at all
adopt a dog today hey you forgot to
clock in this morning
oh yeah i came in behind elias and got
distracted what's going on with his butt
make sure to clock in at some point so
we can start paying you oh hold up wait
i haven't been paid for the last two
hours can't you just adjust the time
sheet
can won't rules of rules are you being
serious
yeah i'm being serious and what's up
with elias's butt as he started cycling
obviously
44 43 42
what are you doing employees may take no
longer than 15 minutes for their lunch
break i've been timing you since you
walked in
you got 40 seconds left come on i needed
to retighten my ponytail i can't go out
there looking like a
rules or rules that's what you said
unless you want to go back on that
35 34. 33
32. oh it's so hot
spurring my mouth less talking more
swallowing god my mouth's good
move i gotta pour one out employees are
allotted one bathroom break
per shift you took one a little earlier
i know cause i wrote it down
that was a false alarm i barely went
we're talking less than a half an ounce
hmm what was it they said about rules
that's right
rules are rules you think this bothers
me
i do a thousand kegels a day i could
break a walnut down there
oh what's the hurry bathroom i'm off the
clock oh you know what
restrooms are for customers only and it
doesn't appear that you've purchased
anything
oh a stapler yeah use this sure you can
and i'll use a stapler you're gonna pay
for this tomorrow oh i don't work
tomorrow then the next day
not until sunday sunday then sunday you
will pay for
oh wait i'm not on sunday damn it this
is so worth the two hours
i hate you so much uh attention cloud9
shoppers
ivan to suck your blood and test it for
diabetes
at insulin kits are now half off are you
looking for a spooktacular savings
because cloud9 has it all you can get um
the pope attention shoppers i want to
suck your blood oh i did that one
oh everybody freeze there's been an
employee theft in the store nobody can
leave i repeat
no one sorry i
i actually just met the employees
customers can leave
so unfreeze
you okay you look sick sick yeah i'm
sick
attention shoppers cloud9 brand tablets
are half off
the halo fog has a hd display and boasts
a battery life of about 45 minutes
hey i need you to work the register
while tim's in the bathroom nah i don't
do registers look i know that it's
really the hip thing for you millennials
to not give a crap
but it's not true and we're the same age
but please go on
it's all hands on deck so quit your
myspacing and get on the register that's
an order
all right let me just finish this
announcement fine but the second you're
done i want you on register three
the second i'm down you can also view
thousands of movies on the halo fog i
will now list some of the movies that
are probably on there
mrs doubtfire silence of the lambs
that one where nicholas cage switches
faces and says he's going to eat a peach
for hours
ooh forrest gump that's a good movie and
then jenae
dies of what is implied to be aids but
we don't know
and he puts haley joel osment on a bus
and guess what same bus driver from the
beginning
what are you still doing here you're
supposed to be on the register you said
i could finish the announcement yeah
that was ten minutes ago
it's a very long announcement next up
apollo 13.
i see what you're doing here in this
film tom hanks is a space man whose life
is saved by a bunch of nerds
and then there's one where tom hanks is
in the airport the whole time
honestly i checked out on that one
anybody see sully
all right oh i don't feel so hot i got
to take a break y'all
oh if you're done with the announcement
register three could use a hand
see i don't give up neither do i
don't forget about polar express merry
christmas kids
it's a nightmare so the first tweet was
sent at 10 46 32.
can we see if anyone was on their phone
then got it okay
looks like brett was on his phone also
jay and uh henry chris
giuseppe w sarah sue
pablo denise giuseppe
okay who's not texting uh elias isn't on
his phone though i think he might be
asleep
may i oh what about the break room is
anybody in there
oh yeah no none of this is from today we
used to have cameras in the break room
but then people found out and got all
rightsy about it
wait wait hold on what was that full
careful stupid birds
nice job
[Music]
luanne if you'll excuse me
i have some business to take care of
hey so random i was going through some
old security footage with luanne
yeah and you remember how we used to
have those security cameras in the break
room
well we came across the time you let all
my birds escape
uh yeah remember that remember it was
valentine's day
remember i was blaming myself for it and
then when i was at my lowest you had sex
with me knowing that hours before you
were the one that let them out
and you knew the entire time and yet you
said nothing remember that
that's so funny dina i'm so so sorry
hey come on don't even worry about it i
forgive you when you think about it this
whole thing is just funny
hey come with me i want to show you
something
they went up so fast it's like they
wanted to burn
what's that sound is that air escaping
from the sneakers
it almost sounds like they're screaming
i will never forgive you ever
hey listen i know we haven't been having
sex recently so i thought i should
explain what's going on
dean i'm with a customer right now oh
i'm sorry step back please can i just
put this step back
there happy anyway i have been
experiencing
some anxiety recently and please don't
spread this around but i've started
going to a shrink
actually two shrinks one's a control
long story short
i've been dealing with some personal
crap okay well um
maybe we just take a little break let
you work on you
oh yeah that would probably be good at
least until i get my
head together we can't take that back if
it's broken
oh that's hard it's sad but true
oh
hey hey garrett
how's it going big guy i'm fine listen
some of us get together on thursdays and
do a little wine club thing you could
join us if you want
why would i do that well you know cause
of what happened
with you and dina how she dumped you
what you are going to find someone so
great
i don't know what you guys heard but i
did not get dumped it was
mutual no
it's never mutual it's never mutual
hey dina ninja turtles are still a thing
huh
i wonder this country's a garbage fire
why did you tell justine that you broke
up with me
because she asked me what's new with you
and so i told her one of my bird says
pink guy i broke up with you and i just
signed up for golf lessons okay but you
didn't
break up with me it was mutual and if
anything i suggested it but i took you
up on it if you had suggested it and i
said no i don't want that
would we still be sleeping together i i
don't know i i guess
but well there you go champ
attention cloud nine employees i am fine
dina did not break up with me and
actually if you want to get real about
it
it was my idea i was trying to be a nice
guy
i got this so if you want to feel bad
for somebody feel bad for dina cause
she's the one
seeing the shrink oh
hey uh i'm sorry about the whole
intercom thing i got carried away and
it wasn't cool it's okay um maybe we
both cared more about this thing between
us than we wanted to admit
it is possible yeah and maybe what i
actually need as i'm processing this
tornado stuff is not to be alone
but to have some support are you saying
you want to get back together
i mean is that crazy
i don't think so let's do it okay
yeah this isn't working out i'm dumping
you what you're dumped
unambiguous sir did you just see that i
dumped him
attention cloud9 employees we have a
non-verbal confirmation i
dumped garrett you're a monster enjoy
wine club
you